[Musique]
olivier minne dire mon chéri tu va
d'abord affronter marie s'infiltre au
jeu du clown me faire tout cas je ne
t'inquiète pas avec tout va bien le jeu
du cloud on va rappeler le principe se
rappelle que tu prêtes tu à animer
l'émission comment ça se passe alors
nous allons donc placé d'abord un
premier clou oui verront enfin ça dépend
ce que tu fais en deux manches on nous
demande une longue marche très bien donc
tu va fixer un cloud comme ça tac essai
le premier de nous deux qui le fiche
complètement
face donc ils enfoncent complètement
dans le billot de bois qui a gagné
exactement et vous taper un coup chacun
apparition c'est parti marie
[Applaudissements]
elle existe à gagner les 500 m'as tu vas
jouer à ce jeu je ne sais pas du tout ce
que c'est et bien ça c'est tout simple
on a la possibilité de retirer un deux
ou trois bateaux name et celui qui reste
en possession du dernier a perdu
exactement
tu peux jouer tu joues avec contre
thomas et alizée maintenant très bien où
j'en suis qui commence allait commencer
à l'aise et en enlève deux
on enlevait un deux ou trois je rappelle
à chaque fois lui qui a le dernier bat
on a perdu il ya 500 euros en jeu pour
l'association
quel club
alors là c'est là c'est maintenant
qu'elle va commencer à falloir faire des
qualités pendant le v3 c'est celui qui
ont restreint qui a gagné eh bien j'ai
perdu j'adore des pays qui enlève le
dernier perdant 9 à 2
prenez votre temps on est bien bonne
idée vous savez vendre leur est confiée
aux marckois 1 2 ou 3 à l heure voilà
bravo très bien joué allez payer vendant
lever 3 et olivier a gagné bravo pour
l'acceptation n'attira henckel alors là
c'est très simple
bien sûr vous allez devoir rester bras
tendus tous les deux en haut du filet
vous savez que le style voilà ces jeunes
mourir le droit mais c'est pas là c'est
moitié koh lanta moitié fort boyard
exactement sur quoi c'est dans le
c'était au conseil
celui qui tiendra le plus longtemps
entre ses oliviers lancé aux douanes ont
fait deux comme ça parce que déjà lui au
doigt c'est une arme et même pour moi je
suis là tu te prends comme ça c'est ma
passion par attendu les deux tu vas tu
dis allez olivier et fait des bras
d'honneur à l'aide il ya 500 euros
attention à ce face à olivier minne
assemble déjà ah ben oui normal ça c'est
10 secondes pour la démarrer à la drogue
ah c'est un vibreur
en neuf ans de moundir dans war bah
ouais bon tu as bastien has
est-ce qu'il tenait en joue pourquoi à
face à olivier bonjour pourquoi vous
êtes déjà dans l'émission s'est déjà
associé non la salle association c'est
l'association de ne pas se faire virer
attention c'est chaud
je les déstabiliser en fait je fais
croire sans vote sur la création du gaz
attendue à cette attention gardez
olivier le bras bien tendus
je ne trompe pas du tout olivier au
moins jouer et je commence lâche olivier
arrête là attention votre bras votre
bras derrière
oui tu peux pas d'emballement aller
[Applaudissements]
olivier il a mille euros pour la
location
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas eu non mais tu vas me dire
plus
alors c'est très simple ça s'appelle le
point tu vois ce site avec moctar varie
d octave exercer une pression sur toit
basse alors si tu remontes et tu fais
tomber la petite balle le baby foot il
sa mère tu as perdu les 500 euros
attention c'est parti bob tahri comme in
peace ce gentil aller à san jose 3 2 1
hier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on veut maintenant face à ludivine à
l'hôpital je connais très bien nous
allons en payer des petites pièces de
bois les unes sur les autres a fait
tomber la tour reliant la partie
ça c'est parti bah si tu ans a alors
malade au centre
on s'appelle ce jeu il ya 500 euros à
gagner hier soir les choses il est 2h30
du matin c'est là qu'olivier minne vient
tenir la course des champions nous a
rejoint
c'est pas du sapin et 2 go chez moi pour
toi ça va sentir le sapin en tout cas
tant vantée à deux doigts d'y arriver
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ça tu connais c'est le vaste
domaine la mémoire je vais vous laisser
en chine
je vais vous laisser 10 10 secondes à
les cinq secondes faut mémoriser le
masters mais le quad vrai mais là il va
gagner leur ont constitué ensuite
d'accord très bien celui qui aura la
meilleure combinaison gagnera et 500
euros
ouf oui c'est pas un petit 5 ps voilà
3 on land leblanc a jamais trop ça déjà
il démarre pas pareil je me rappelle
plus de ce côté là alors on va parler de
se doter un bleu rose et d'orange
à partir de ce côté on va partir de ce
côté mais vous avez vu la même chose
n'était pas dans le coup venir je sais
pas moi la photo que j'ai pardonné
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il gagne son appui
[Applaudissements]
nous entendrons olivier mettons en face
de moi à oui ça si tu connais le jeu du
real alors celui qui noie le vert a bien
entendu perdu vous connaissez le jeu
chez vous attention tu veux commencer
notation à s'y attaquer photo là dessus
il fait ça à penser au patois non moi
j'ai au conseil et ont demandé de ne pas
venir pour les raisons qui les regardent
[Musique]
à te dire ça
oh
[Musique]
ah la la alors là c'est très très chaud
lors de question que je percevais curé
culture l'autre côté pitt a coulé la
sauce c'est quasiment impossible aussi
tu peux le faire au début non excusez
moi ça olivier la clé voilà à la pause
la pièce se doucement bien joué
[Applaudissements]
il aima le paquet et n'est pas bien me
donne un peu d'élan les séries c'est un
poste on n'a pas de magouilles
ça va passer ça va pas passer cheryl
alalala c'est pas vrai geek on pas alors
olivier minne ben moi c'est qu'il m
malgré la péniche chiabodo l'ont tué
olivier crâne est là bas je pense que
j'ai encore une petite chance à tous est
petit c'est tout ce que tu as a way
[Applaudissements]
mais olivier bien entendu qu'on t'offre
perd mille euros pour te réfères ton
c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
la série vient fouet